alright it looks like we're now live for
the pop up so today we're going to be
talking primarily about stoicism and I
may answer some other questions or
comments that have to do with with other
things but we're going to give priority
to discussing stoicism and this pop up
since that's the theme so we'll see if
we can come back to other questions or
things like that I'll also mention as
we're getting warmed up that if you
haven't caught the video or the podcast
of our inaugural radio show wisdom for
life that's hosted by myself and Dan
Hayes you might want to check that out
we're gonna be broadcasting from
Riverwest radio every other Friday 5:00
to 6:00 p.m. Central Time and so you
know we we don't talk exclusively about
stoicism but it is oriented towards
practical philosophy and philosophy as a
way of life so if you're into that sort
of thing then you might want to check in
because you can hear not just on in
Milwaukee but you know since we have the
internet you can hear it pretty much
anywhere in the world
alright so let's see what we've got here
I'm gonna skip with Chesterton question
save that for an AMA or for one of the
other ones
let's see Matthew Hopkins unraveling
layers of self-delusion and not getting
in your own way seems to me the greatest
psychological task for the stoic perhaps
a life's work I'd love to know if you
see this as a valid idea do you I
actually have two ideas they're right on
layering unraveling layers of
self-delusion and not getting your own
away or not constituting an impediment
yourself do different things that are
quite important to stoic philosophy yeah
I would say that those are
among it the certainly stoic philosophy
is not reducible to those two motifs
boat it is those are those are important
and you know we can speak more broadly
of virtue ethics in general so it's not
just a stoic thing or you know an
Aristotelian thing or platonic thing and
we can also talk about religious
traditions as well you know if you look
at Krishna Buddha thought Hindu thought
you look at a lot of thoughtful people
belonging to particular wisdom
traditions figuring out who you are and
how you've got who you are is really
quite central to things and so yeah that
you know you can think of wisdom
traditions or philosophical traditions
as offering us ways to analyze ourselves
progressively because it's never like we
get get it you know
it all figured out just in in one big
flash we you know chip away at it we
figure out what's wrong with over time
bruce says flow dr. Saylor I'm happy to
see Bruce here as always let's see most
we've got NamUs come EHT marcus aurelius
and executing christians and i talked
about much and Peter
Iram responds Donald Robertson debunks
the myth of Marcus Aurelius executing
Christians yeah Donald Donald the bunks
that so did quite a few Aurelius did in
fact have some Christians executed but
it wasn't you know some massive pogrom
or something like that they weren't
really that much on his radar I mean
they they were a group among many right
and and you know if you look at Justin
martyrs apology it's it's addressed of
the Roman Emperor specifically you know
because he thinks that Christians are
being persecuted but you know we have to
be careful when we use this word
persecution does it mean like throwing
people in you know into the circus and
having Lions tear them
which is a rather dramatic thing or does
it mean you know bringing course of
pressure to bear on them and you know
Aurelius was a Roman Emperor he's
primarily concerned with maintaining
some sort of social order the Christians
and you know also Jews were quite
disruptive within the Roman Empire in
some respects all right so let's let's
see what else we have here about
stoicism Brittany Paige can you please
talk about Pan pantheism and stoicism so
so pantheism is the idea that everything
is God right and you could say that the
stoic physics is pantheistic it's
probably better to describe it as pan
and theistic which means that typically
when we use this term in religious
studies or in philosophy of religion
were instead of saying that everything
is part of you know one giant organism
that is God or mechanism or whatever we
want to say we say that there's there is
still some sort of hierarchy there so
you know when you say that everything is
God it sounds like everything is kind of
leveled out and the Stoics think that
the human being is quite literally you
know or at least a part of the human
being and by the way it's not just the
Stoics who think this you know platanus
Aristotelian x' have similar conceptions
is is sort of like a piece of God or a
spark of God or a reflection of the
divine and that part of us is the
rational part right so it's not it's not
just our body or our animality or
something like that and so you know you
look at epictetus and he'll he'll draw
some conclusions from this you'll say
that slave that you're treating badly
they're also you know a child of God
just like you and he'll also say you
shouldn't go off to the whorehouse
because when you do your mixing god in
with with prostitutes and all of that
sort of stuff so there's the Stoics are
not pantheistic in the sense of like
leveling all distinctions and just
saying well everything is a piece or
function of God capital G god Zeus right
they have you know God is the conception
of this entire universe or the divine
reason running through it and then they
have all sorts of lowercase G gods and
you know we don't know that much about
their their theology as we'd like to
because a lot of the texts have but
probably the place for that arose on the
nature of the gods bow to or it's
discussed them also on divination where
things like that are being discussed as
well to a lesser extent um but you know
modern toast them it's that that stuff
really isn't that important there are
some people who are quite committed to
that they call themselves traditional
Stoics and they say that all the other
modern stoic start you know misguided
but it's a monster works I actually
think that we can dispense with the
stoic theology all right let's see what
else we got first quick questions even
Nana's his stoicism relevant and reading
Hegel what philosophers are important
understand him know stoicism isn't
particularly important for reading Hegel
Hagel does talk about the Stoics but
doesn't appear to have understood them
particularly well and in in the you know
lectures on the history of philosophy
says that we we can't really be stoic or
Epicureans or any of the other skeptics
of the the old sort in the presence and
the present for him is remember a good
hundred and 180 hundred ninety years ago
no actually to more than two hundred
years ago now our in 2020 right
what other philosophers are relevant to
reading Hegel
you know everyone who mentioned Kant of
course but we're so quite important as
well you probably need to know a good
bit about modern philosophy in general
you you want to know a good bit about
Plato and Aristotle so you know you read
around pretty widely and also remember
too that it's not just reading
philosophers to understand Hegel but but
you know philosophies for Hegel
something broader than just what we what
we consider philosophy in the narrow
sense today I'm gonna take a question
from Andre and I'm gonna twist it in a
stoic way do I recommend any books or
authors for learning how to think
clearly or even Lear real-life exercises
for that there's nothing better than
making distinctions and practicing
making distinctions when you see people
in an argument about something ask
yourself are they actually arguing about
the same thing you know or are they
arguing past each other that's something
that philosophers when they're they're
doing a good job really bring to the
table and you know studying stoic
philosophy will will help with that
quite a bit because you'll see them
doing that there's nothing like actually
reading philosophical texts in which
people are doing that sort of work and
there's really nothing like grappling
with philosophical texts that are
outside of your comfort zone so they're
not written like an academic article
that you might find in analytic
philosophy of the present or not written
like you know the cutting-edge
continental stuff that you're used to
there's nothing like that to push you
out of your intellectual comfort zone
and help you attend to what argument
looks like and you could say a similar
thing you're gonna hear the dog drinking
over there for a little while you can
say a similar thing with you know like
studying movements and Chinese
philosophy you know or studying
Aristotle or you know reading Platonic
dialogues and not just like trying to
say okay what's the what's the argument
here what's the heart of
that but actually reading the whole
dialogue and then comparing it with
other dialogues doing that sort of work
is going to make you a better thinker
because you're in effect working out in
the intellectual gym all right
metamorphosis do I think a stoic has on
them the burden of explaining my wife
why life is worth taking seriously in
order to convince a cynic or hedonist to
reconsider their position I don't think
a stoic has a burden of explaining
anything to anybody that's not inherent
in in the philosophy as such if they
want to they can but you know it's not
as if we we have an absolute requirement
to like oh you've embraced this
particular philosophical position you
have you must defend it against all
comers and explain yourself to anybody
who asks and know that that that's not
the case very often in philosophy people
aren't you know they've they've got
their pet position and they they're
they're not receptive at a particular
point in time and when they are
receptive then you could explain things
to them I mean you could say the same
thing about should we try you know if
you if you like Descartes should we try
to you know explain why Descartes is is
the best philosopher you know if we like
Aristotle and it's not as if Epicureans
are set or cynics or hedonist don't
think life is worth taking seriously
they just have a different way of
approaching it you know hedonist think
that we should try to maximize our
pleasure and reduce pain whether they're
if we're talking an ancient philosophy
whether they're an heiress to peon
hedonist or an epicurean hedonist they
were just as serious as the Stoics were
and the cynics were too they called
themselves heralds of God they were
thinking that they were there to not
just you know masturbate in the
marketplace or show everybody what it
you know cool detached person they were
that's only you know a portion of what
cynics did they were actually trying to
show that virtue was the the only good
and to do so by haranguing their fellow
citizens and doing you know all sorts of
crazy modeling stuff so yeah all right
let's see philosophy and critical
thinking gender feminist theorists often
include stoicism their definition of
toxic traditional masculinity not my
view just wondering what your responses
to this treatment of stoicism I'm some
do and some don't and to the degree that
they do they're either talking about
stoicism and I notice that you you're
using lowercase s stoicism which already
you know is not stoicism the stoicism
that we're talking about uppercase s the
philosophy and so I think it's kind of a
common set of mix-ups and mistakes
here comes sassy cat wanting to get my
lap 17 years old she doesn't she doesn't
care about online events or things like
that
all right so there are a lot of guys out
there who really are you know toxic as
human beings and they have all sorts of
stupid and misguided conceptions of
masculinity and they do in fact bring up
the south of the Stoics and try to use
them as talking points and usually they
don't know what they're talking about we
call that Brewis ism right we have a
name for that in the modern stoic
movement because there's so many you
know dude bros out there doing that and
talking all sorts of crazy stuff about
you know usually they're also super fans
of the spartans but they don't know
anything about the spartans
quite frankly they the more they they're
drawing on like watching the 300 or
something like that and so you know to
the degree that that's what's in the
crosshairs of gender or feminist
theorists they're actually right if
that's what stoicism means then then
stoicism is toxic and and quite frankly
as garbage and when I run into guys like
that you know I I feel kind of it's a
shame that they're doing that to
themselves because they're usually never
happy individuals even when they managed
to dominate people and they
misunderstood
am the doctrine that they want a claim
you know I bet you know you can say the
same thing about Nietzsche ins right
there's plenty of guys out there who
want to be you BER mention and and you
know they're not they they use a little
bit of thought now when it comes to
actual stoicism what the the actual
Stoics taught and what people in the
present who are well informed by stoic
philosophy put into practice yeah then
the gender theorists are wrong because
you know it's it's not going to be about
the things that we call toxic
masculinity and I'll go on record to by
the way and say I think there is such a
thing as toxic masculinity I've seen it
many times there's plenty of it out
there you know it exists today it
existed when I was a kid I you know have
fallen into it at various times you know
particularly when I was younger and I
thankfully was able to get my way out of
it and I'm a much happier person for not
that but no stoicism an actual lawsuit
say well that's all garbage that's
damaging to you oh you know that's
probably a sufficient answer to that
coffee smug here's a good question who
is my favorite contemporary stoic
Christopher Gill I would say and I would
say that in part because I really like
Chris's writings
and I've met him and you know actually
had the chance to hang out with him from
time to time and he's sort of the elder
statesman of the modern stoic movement
and the modern stoicism organization and
he's an all-around good guy he is very
thoughtful and I enjoy hanging out with
him when I get to it's kind of you know
like hanging out with a rock star and I
love the stuff that he writes I mean I
also you really do like a long-long
doesn't identify strictly as a stoic but
I really do like his stuff he's also
cool when I got to meet him
you know there's quite a few people that
kind of fit that bill Margaret graver
gulia honest and then there's a whole
you know crop of other people as well so
alright um what else have we got about
stoicism here we go
Matthew Hopkins I understand Epictetus
Seneca and Marcus Aurelius or
late-period Stoics can you recommend any
earlier writers beyond xenos fragments
yeah I mean here's here's one thing to
say to begin with you actually get a lot
of the earlier writers through Seneca
and to a lesser extent through epictetus
because they they actually provide us
with fragments of what these people
taught but all the other earlier Stoics
that we have are indeed fragmentary I
mean we have a little bit of Epictetus
teacher mu Sonia's Rufus as well and we
do have you know another contemporary
author Heracles his writings but for the
most part what we've got is going to be
coming from sources about the Stoics
rather than from Stoics and you know
it's I think a lot of people fall into
the misconception of thinking that oh
man you know it's important to get
closer to the source closer to the
origin point it's just not that way in
philosophy
Epictetus is just as good of a stoic as
Zeno was as cruciferous was as Diogenes
Babylon was you know or posted Oh Gnaeus
was posted Onias by the way you know was
criticized as not being an orthodox
stoic by the orthodox Stoics of his time
but he was the more interesting and
innovative stoic and you can say the
same thing about seneca same thing about
marcus aurelius there it's not as if
there's anything bad about being later
now if you want to read what we've got
of earlier authors you need to go to
people who are talking about them or
providing the fragments so Cicero's a
big one
plutarch who's kind of hostile to the
Stoics is another Gailen talks about
cruciferous mainly you know he thinks
chris apes' has got things wrong but he
tells us what cruciferous had to say
diogenes layer tastes of course has the
entire you know book seven devoted to
the Stoics areas didymus has the epitome
of stoic ethics which is kind of dry but
worth reading so though those are all
you know places you can go you're not
gonna find you will find books out there
that purport to be here Zeno but it's
really just collating the fragments that
we have of Zeno and saying well here you
go and there is a book out there
similarly called the philosophy of
cruciferous that I think is doing the
same sort of thing alright John cynics
embody the true Socratic philosophy
prove me wrong I don't need to prove you
wrong I mean you want to think that
cynics embody the truthful Socratic
philosophy I guess you're a cynic I
don't think that's the case I think that
you know there's a pluralism of Socratic
philosophies there's Platonism there's
the Megerian school you know the Stoics
are in effect a Socratic school Cicero
recognized that the Aristotelian Tsar a
Socratic school but hey you want to
think that the cynics are the only game
in town you go right on ahead because
you just basically ended the
conversation right there that's not the
way to try to hold a a philosophical
conversation let's see here Chad maples
is it true that there is a relationship
between stoicism and Judaism on the
whole no but in parts yes because
different
movements within Judaism were of course
influenced by the Greek culture that
dominated the the Near East because of
the conquests of Alexander and the
successor States and stuff like that and
you know the Jewish you know thinkers
and and movements were also influenced
to a considerable extent by the Persians
and by by others as well so you know
it's not as if that is if there's
something out there that's that's you
know Capital J Judaism that was
influenced but there's plenty of of
movements and you know you can if you
read the the books of the Maccabees for
example the first two of which are
considered to be canonical for all of
the earlier churches it's only it's only
later on with with the Protestants that
people don't consider them to be
canonical you're gonna find a lot of
stoic actions and by the time that you
get to fourth Maccabees which is not
considered canonical but was you know
clearly read by people because you know
they thought it was an important text in
some groups there's a lot of stoicism
there but you can also find a lot of
Platonism I mean look at the Book of
Wisdom you know the wisdom of Solomon
again you know canonical for for
Catholics Orthodox Eastern Christians
I'm just not or just not canonical for
for most Protestants
that's pretty influenced by by
Neoplatonism and so yeah you'll find
some things like that and then you know
it'd be interesting to think about what
would be the case if stoicism had
survived longer in as its own school
rather than as something that
essentially got sucked into just like a
wrist italian ism got into neoplatonism
in many cases all right let's see what
else we got here
[Music]
let's see open just jumped a little bit
let's see if we can find
she had maples asks Massimo thoughts I
liked Massimo he's a colleague of mine
we don't always agree on everything but
we don't have to and I interact with him
you know fairly frequently usually it
face-to-face at least once a year and
you know he and I actually went through
philosophical counseling training and
certification together back in was a
2014 I think it was down in New York
City so you know were we're colleagues
we correspond from time to time we you
know because we're both out there I
think he's in a much more he's got a
much bigger digital footprint than I do
but we sometimes compare notes about how
we handle trolls or you know when we
when we move ourselves out of a
conversation when a conversation is not
particularly useful and we've we've
swapped ideas about like how to do
public philosophy events so and you know
I like his book I did a review of it how
to be a stoic I don't you know there's
things where I don't agree with him
completely or with Peter Steinke which
was also you know a good colleague of
mine I think they are I think that that
living in accordance with nature is a
more complicated thing than they think
it is but you know those are sort of
variances within the same kind of
movement alright Thomas Moore best stuff
to read on mortality well if you're
talking about Stoics classic Stoics
right Seneca has a lot to say about that
you know and so a lot of people start
with their Seneca reading the letters to
lick Ilyas or sometimes they're called
the moral epistles that's a big thick
book right but he's also got these
consolations that are worth checking out
because some of those are consolations
when somebody's kid has died right and
so there there's some reflections on
death Epictetus has some good stuff to
say about that you know running
throughout the discourses and the
enchiridion marcus aurelius of course
has quite a few you know great passages
about that and he's writing you know as
an older person with epictetus epictetus
of course didn't write these things down
is his biographer area and did and that
was presumably earlier and Epictetus
--is tenure as a teacher he lived quite
long to then again Seneca stuff he's
writing it you know he's fairly old when
he's writing to so you know they're all
approaching mortality so that that's
that's good alright Chad maples Greg
with Socrates really just the best
sophist no that's you know it's funny I
do sometimes get people when they read a
republic book one they're like Socrates
is just you know shutting through Simic
us up and he's not he doesn't really
have any good arguments and that's wrong
to begin with there are some good
arguments in there but he doesn't
usually waste his good arguments on
people who can't appreciate him there's
you know the dramatic context counts in
platonic dialogues and I don't know how
anyone would get the idea that Socrates
is just another sophist in widely
reading Platonic dialogues or even
Xenophon dialogues
you know Xenophon is another witness to
what Socrates was like now does that
mean that he's diametrically opposed to
the Sophists on every point no in part
because the sophist were not all one
group that we're all on one single page
to you know Protagoras is different than
gorgeous is different than through Simic
as' and they each have their own way of
doing things they're different than
hideous as well
so yeah all right Matt Henderson any
suggestions on stoic philosophy or
philosophers that can help with
self-discipline when it comes to
schoolwork philosophy major you know the
same again the same Stoics that we have
seneca Epictetus Marcus Aurelius I will
say this you you don't have to feel like
you have to read everybody you know I
the person I prefer the most is
epictetus you know I like a rally Asst
but I I think he's kind of like all over
the map and I you know I think that
Seneca is kind of I enjoy reading him
but I don't enjoy reading him like I do
Epictetus and maybe there maybe there's
some temperament involved so when you're
reading this stuff you don't always have
to like try to as we say boil the ocean
right I think it's less about reading
things and more about actually
practicing so you know could be helpful
to remind yourself of certain passages
like where Epictetus for example says
okay you know consider what you're
getting into if you're gonna try to you
know develop discipline your it's like
becoming a wrestler you're gonna it's
and thrown in your eyes or you get
thrown down you have to get back up so
if you if you have that like in the back
your mind when you encounter
difficulties and fail that you can say
well okay what would Epictetus say about
this now now I can put that into
practice but the putting it into
practice that's the key thing right
discipline is something that develops
over time by making yourself do things
that you are not inclined to do running
the extra mile or you know putting it
like in my case going through and
grading all of these student papers
without taking a break to look at
Twitter you know or or you know get up
and have a sandwich or something like
that alright buckling down and sticking
with it there's there's no substitute
for that you might benefit though from
thinking by carrying out a sort of
analysis and thinking about well why
don't you stick
something what's going on in you that
tempts you to abandon the tasks that you
would like to persevere in so that you
know that can be helpful I think all
right let's see what else we've got here
all right Brittany Paige what are your
arguments on what are your thoughts on
Senecas argument against forgiveness and
for mercy doing an independent study on
it are you talking about in on clemency
Seneca actually does think you should
forgive in a lot of cases and you should
show mercy and he provides a whole bunch
of different considerations so I'm not
sure which which one you have in mind I
will say that I mean it's kind of cool
that you do see this there's there's
often this take of like oh you know the
Greek pagans they they understood some
things and but Christianity had to come
along and clarify all these other things
that the Greeks had no idea about like
you know how good forgiveness was you
know like what I mean it's there in
Plato Aristotle discusses it the Stoics
discuss it you know where is this this
need to you know put things down like
that coming from
I mean Seneca is is it you know it's
another thing to think about to Seneca
is also living in a time when for
generations the incapacity to to let
grudges and factional strife go had torn
Rome apart and then replaced the
dysfunctional military Tribune's and
councils and Senate with well the Senate
was still there but it fortunately
became you know sort of defamed with
with an emperor you know an imperial
structure
which if you got the wrong person and
could really go off the rails and Seneca
is writing some of these works to Nero
before Nero revealed himself as the
screw-up that he was so that I think
that might be helpful to think about as
well all right let's see what else we've
got here I just skipped a little bit
Andre yes can i clarify the concept of
apatheia tried to apply the wisdom of
Senecas letters and mortify the passions
but later felt that I needed those
passions as fuel to life well the Stoics
don't say that you should actually not
have any passions you know you you
probably want to read Seneca more
closely in the discussions of the
emotions and again you want to look at
dodging easily our tastes and Cicero
also talks about this in in Tusculum
meditations disputation sorry and areas
did a mess right in his epitome the
Stoics thought that the goal was not to
repress emotion but rather to transform
it so mortifying the passions depending
on how you're doing it may or may not be
a viable strategy just shoving
everything down inside or saying it
doesn't doesn't affect me when it does
affect you that's not going to work you
actually have to understand why you're
feeling the way that you're feeling and
then you can start working away at it
and saying okay am I making the right
assumptions here or judgments or is what
I'm doing off-base do I want to feel
like this you know apatheia is not a
emotionless state it's a lack of the
path a it's not a lack of the a path a a
the good emotions which include love you
know which include affection
and you know there's all sorts of good
discussions of these again in in arias
did mrs. epitome of stoic ethics now the
passions is fuel to life there is one
thing that you do want to keep in in
mind so from from the stoic point of
view a Seneca talks about this a non
anger right the Aristotelian would say
oh you need you need anger in order to
like get the right thing done so you get
angry at injustice now that gets you
ready to go March and fight against the
unjust tyrant and Seneca says can't you
accomplish that with with reason instead
of the passion of anger and if you can't
if you need anger is like a crutch like
that it's kind of unreliable and it
often goes in the wrong direction maybe
you need to be strengthening your reason
your Faculty of reasons so you can
actually get yourself to do the right
thing without having to get all riled up
with it and it's really interesting this
is something I've been thinking about
and I'm going to do some writing on
there's so many people when you respond
to them critically and you say now
you've got that wrong or you probably
shouldn't have said that they're like
why are you so angry with me and you're
like buddy I'm not angry with you I'm
just saying that you've actually got
this wrong and you're you're spouting
nonsense or something like that or you
probably shouldn't be weighing in on you
know somebody else's sites with your BS
right and you can say that without
getting angry with somebody you can just
call a spade a spade you can say
somebody is screwing up and and and just
leave it at that right so all right
let's see what else we've got
[Music]
ah here's a
a good thing from Matthew so cobblestone
he means Friedrich cobblestone with a
history of philosophy can't claim
stoicism came about as the Hellenistic
world became part of the Roman Empire
yeah
so that's true but it didn't actually
happen at that point in time stoicism is
is around before the Romans had like
gobbled up holy the eastern
Mediterranean right so and stoicism
makes its way to Rome otherwise you
couldn't have had Diogenes of Babylon
being one of the three ambassadors of
the philosophical schools going to Rome
and getting Cato the Elder to say we
shouldn't we shouldn't trust these these
Greek philosophers so you know the other
thing that cobblestone buys into that
you see very often in treatments of
Hellenistic philosophy really from about
the early 1800s on to I would say the
nineteen it was a common view until
about the 1970s and now now you know
more attentive reading and you know less
ideological interpretations you know a
said I that's that's not not true so
there's this this story right that the
Greek city-state was the most absolutely
important thing in Greek democracy and
all this sort of stuff and ignoring the
fact that most Greek city-states were
pushed around by other Greek city-states
and forced into the leagues and they
were interdependent and all this this
stuff long before the Macedonian
conquest but there's this look you know
sort of story like well fill up a
Macedon United Greece and then freedom
went out the window it became
meaningless and the Greek city-state
could no longer be the locus of things
so people turned inward they became
individualistic I mean all you got to do
is read Plato's dialogues and the
individual is individualist all over the
place we read through cities right and
you'd be disabused of that but the idea
was
that stoicism skepticism and
Epicureanism are in some way less
philosophical they're they're kind of
defective they're they're only really
interested in in ethical responses to
the problem of what do we do now right
and they are actually response as to
what do we do now
but the Aristotelian of the plaintiffs
we're also doing that at the same time
and the what do we do now could cover a
lot of different things cobble students
treatment of the Stoics is adequate it's
not great I wouldn't I wouldn't rely on
it too heavily I think he's better on
some some thinkers than he is on others
all right John how would you compare
Nietzsche's criticisms of stoicism and
his will to power compared to stoicism
for finding fulfillment out of life yeah
I mean Nietzsche's criticisms of
stoicism aren't really that that on
point he criticizes them for stoah
sizing nature he has a different
conception of nature this is one of
those sort of things where you know when
you're deciding which way you're gonna
go you'd go this way or you go this way
but you can't go both and Nietzsche is
going this way and then criticizing the
Stoics for not having gone that way and
you know I think that's that's perfectly
fine you know at some points you can't
make everything compatible I think that
Nietzsche's criticisms of somehow some
people have used stoicism are not bad
you know I think those could be on point
I've seen plenty of people in the stoic
forums act like rows on to Mont Phil
jerks to each other but then they're not
really being Stoics right they're not
living up to the stoicism and you know
again they're two very different
conceptions of things Nietzsche doesn't
think that there's Nietzsche's
ultimately a pluralist when it comes
down to whatever the ontology is there's
will the power but will the power takes
all these different shapes and
forms and you know one thing where you
can say that they have something in
common they realize that the human being
is a screwed up creature and it's it's
screwed up in part because it's various
drives and ideas and all these different
things jumbled around inside of it that
have material correlates but all right
we can also understand in in not
strictly material ways that these are in
conflict and contradiction with each
other as a matter of fact Epictetus uses
the word mocking they are at war with
each other and part of the goal is to
figure out what we want to give priority
over what and that's where Nietzsche and
the Stoics have different answers that's
getting dark now you can see the
lightest is changing as the sun goes
down so yeah that's that's probably
enough of a answer to that all right
let's see here Peter Aram if there's
time could you comment on the connection
between the social virtue of justice and
the modern idea of social justice yeah
if you're a stoic you're actually for
social justice and social justice you
know it emerges in the is as a word in
the 19th century John Stuart Mill uses
it you'll find him talking about it of
course it plays a role in in socialist
and Marxist and other other you know
thought on the left and it it gets used
by by other people as well and it also
has important uses within Catholic
thought and so you know when we when we
haven't hear this word social justice we
want to ask okay what it's sort of like
almost MacIntyre whose justice which
rationality which social justice are we
talking about are we talking about some
book you know some some Hobgoblin or
what's what's the word that I was
thinking of something you know the MA
that that hides under your bed Bugaboo
right of conservatives or their like
social justice warriors are ruining
everything and they know what the hell
they're talking about most of the time
you know the people who are being tired
as social justice warriors usually don't
have much of an interest in actual
social justice they're interested in
some sort of you know Rhian position of
power on somebody else or reversing
things but you know if we think about
what social justice means it means that
that part of justice that has to do with
the way societies organized and
something could be you know I was
talking about this with my wife just the
other day right we think about health
care and you know one of the things in
this election that's being talked about
is universal health care and it should
be because that's something that should
be provided to citizens in you know as
much wealth as we're generating in our
economy we can afford it and we can
certainly take money away from [ __ ]
Wars and stuff like that and all the
pissed away money that we spend on the
military and I say that as a vet as
somebody who's who's served and
supported the military and most vets
would actually say the military gets too
much money and it spends it poorly we
should be spending it on other
priorities so you know you think about
we're now framing it as Medicare for all
right why is that such an important
thing because so many people are without
adequate health care or if they do have
insurance it's extraordinarily expensive
it keeps them from being able to
participate in American life in
important ways because it sucks up so
much money and so much time and it's so
arbitrary and there are people who are
you know rationing their insulin and as
that sort of thing doesn't bother you
because you've you know got some some
ideological jag going on you're you're a
bad person I mean if you don't care
about your fellow human being suffering
on mass in that way there's there's
something deeply flawed you know I mean
you could say well the money gets spent
badly
then you you you fix that right so you
know medicare-for-all is a social
justice issue was it necessarily so
forty years ago no because our
healthcare system was not as screwed up
back then things change over time and so
we have to be attentive to what needs to
be done so you know now it should it
should actually be a priority and you
know anybody who's who's saying oh you
know you cost too much you're buying
into those things or take away
individual freedom most of those lies
and and shame on those people for buying
into and repeating and believing those
lives because truth is a value you know
and if it can be done in other countries
as it is being done in other countries
it can be done here it's just we lack
the political will to do so and an easy
way of saying that is we lack the will
for social justice and there's many
other issues as well
anti racism you know society at least
American society and you can talk about
other societies and other ways there is
structural racism that's not a a made up
thing and if you're a stoic and you care
about justice you should care about that
because there's two sides to justice as
Cicero explains right there's like
fairness and following the rules and
fulfilling commitments and stuff like
that that would you know argue against
racism and then there's benevolence
which is another part of justice doing
good to people and and going beyond just
what the rules requires so I mean for me
this is kind of a no-brainer if you're
actually a stoic and you want to live in
accordance with what Stoics taught you
would be for social justice you might
not be for what what you know people
that evergreen college are calling it
but they're a tiny little fringe you
know for the most part social justices
you know what you're doing with your
neighbor how you're living in your
community where the tax money is going
where the priorities are if the schools
are being funded
you know if the communities are being
made safe but not being terrorized by
police all those all those things fit
in there and a stoic would be for those
things all right a lot of talk about
that design Belen that's that that's
Bruce asking who or how did
philosophical counseling start so that's
a good question
and if we want to talk about a
recognized profession that we call
philosophical counseling it's it's
fairly recent so it's you know a couple
decades old in Europe where it was done
a little bit earlier it's called
philosophical practice but it's really
the same thing you're using resources
from philosophy to understand and and
work on common life problems and
organizational problems and oftentimes
you know like looking at the emotions or
things like that
now I said it's a really good question
because that's what the ancient platanus
Aristotelian Stoics Epicureans even
skeptics cynics that's what they were
doing they were engaged in philosophical
counseling they just didn't call it that
they called it practicing philosophy we
got to the point with because the
academic philosophy essentially took
over philosophy in and really only in
the last 200 years
it's a rarely recent phenomena Descartes
if you look at what he's doing in his
works he's doing philosophical
counseling as well right he's doing
philosophy as a way of life he's not
doing merely academic philosophy and I
think you can say the same thing about
David Hume as well
definitely Thomas Hobbes so
philosophical counseling as the
phenomena that it is it's been with us
for a very long time and it's not just
in Western philosophy it's also in all
sorts of non Western philosophies as
well and you can find overlaps with
religion and other disciplines too all
right let's see here
bellavita did a single person on earth
actually practice stoicism yep plenty of
people of practice stoicism matter of
fact I would say at this point you know
if not millions hundreds of thousands
now how much it depends on the person
right but yeah there's I mean there's
there's I think tens of thousands at
least of people right now practicing it
today so sure all right Chad says we
have so many distractions so it's
difficult to keep it Greek modern tech
and entertainment well that's that's
that's an interesting thing to say the
Greeks didn't keep it Greek in ancient
times either philosophy was always a
minority practice right and most people
were were distracted by other kinds of
tech and entertainment just read
juvenile satires and and that will get
home to you what ancient Rome was like
you know all the different things going
on but you know you can read Seneca or
you could read Plato or you could read
Plutarch or whoever and there they're
all saying over and over again century
after century man people really have the
wrong priorities I mean that's that's
what got Socrates into his job right if
you want to call it a job that reminds
me actually have a line from Louie
Ferdinand Celine's voyage Oh Buddha did
Murray said neti air this deceitful to a
this this job of getting yourself killed
he talked about the first world war like
that I'm not exactly it was a voyage was
a journey into the end of night his
English translation right
I mean Socrates was going around to all
of his fellow-citizens and saying man
your priorities are screwed up you're
spending all this time on like you know
trying to get prestige or enjoy yourself
with this sort of stuff focus on your
soul man so it's not a recent phenomenon
it's it's it's there and it's probably
always going to be with us I imagine
right okay let's see here oh here's a
good one from Bella Vita how does
ancient Greek stoicism differ from self
discipline within the various Buddhist
and Christian traditions there's a lot
of overlap actually and oh you know
that's where he could draw some nice
comparisons I would say that the
metaphysics are different right and
they're different so I think about
Buddhism and the ocean of emptiness and
the there were some minority Buddhists
who actually thought there was a self
the majority view that one out was there
is there is no self well extinct assault
right so it's a there's a fundamental
difference there but it's a self that
doesn't survive physical death Senecas a
little cagey about this but for the most
part it doesn't that's different the
Christians who think that there is a
immortal soul right and then we can talk
about how the how the gods or whatever
we want to call it I mean some people
say well Buddhism doesn't have guys yeah
it does I mean just take a look at
Mahayana and Vajrayana Buddhism and
there's plenty of deities right and
people are doing things with them and
praying to them and they played an
important role but you know how do these
things function
do we interact with them I mean if
Stoics for example wouldn't bother
praying there's no point right
whereas Christians do and by the way
sort of sort of a lot of Buddhists you
know just go to a Pure Land temple
sometime and see people chanting and ask
them what they're chanting and why
they're chanting so there's some some
important differences there how do they
differ from self-discipline
so discipline that's where it gets
really interesting a lot of the same
techniques can be found and used within
these different traditions and even the
Epicureans kind of get in on this too
right or or other other traditions and
other religions due to Hinduism has as a
lot of different disciplinary practices
Sufi interpretations of Islam and there
are some very you know long deep root
Sufi schools that have developed a lot
of interesting but what Foucault later
calls technologies of the soul or
technologies of the self right there's a
lot of those and you can borrow them
from each other I I think that you know
Christian monasticism which is full of
you know techniques and practices you
know you look at John Cassian I think
there's some stuff that's drawn from
stoicism in there or at least compatible
with it so yeah all right let's see what
else we get here I just jumped again see
if we got some stoic things
so kujan says what is the purpose of
passion then but too few illogical
reason the presumption is that emotions
are to be denied or suppressed in order
for logic to blossom maybe passion fuels
correct reasons so so your idea is that
you would use passion to make yourself
more rational I don't think a stoic
would really agree with that but maybe
I'm misunderstanding you there linden
asks how does your stoic side treat your
former Nietzschean productivity's i mean
i wouldn't say that they're all totally
gone right and so you know if you think
about anger as as something that
Nietzsche is probably you know pretty
bullish about you can say or at least
Agra Civet II from a stoic perspective
you want you know you want to you want
to figure out why you're you're upset to
begin with the men start chipping away
at that stuff I would say that you know
I was talking with with somebody about
this today then I think that there's
there's you know there's quite a few
things to nature that are kind of cool
and useful and he is right about some
things but I think the the overall
project is something I don't I don't
really have that much sympathy with
anymore there is a danger of nihilism
there is there is you know a danger of
falling into the you know transvaluation
of values which I do think is something
that that can be understood is
particularly modern and applies just as
much to conservatives as it does to
liberals or leftists or anything like
that there's so many different ways of
being a phony
from Nietzsche's perspective I think a
lot of deaths that's right and I think
we do want to avoid result a month but I
think the Stoics offer us other
resources I don't know there's for me
all this is kind of still a work in
progress
I won't claim to have like some sort of
harmonious everything living together in
my head and heart perfectly well I just
you know I'm a pluralist in philosophy
or an eclectic if you like and I draw up
on what works for me and and bring to
bear what works for my clients as well
all right Brittany is a clarification to
clarify my previous question on clemency
Seneca says forgiveness comes from a
place of anger and unequal Authority
whereas mercy comes from a place of
compassion and equitable treatment he
said something around forgiveness being
an added action waters mercy as in
action and Stoics don't do additional
actions okay well there you go
he's using these in very precise ways
that make sense within his framework I
wouldn't try to extend that outside of a
stoic framework and say well you know
see what the Christians say about this
or the Aristotelian say about this
because they're working with a different
psychology in that case what else do we
have
loss whereas what's your favorite stoic
quote I don't actually have one I'm not
a I'm not a good person to ask about
favorites because I never know I don't
know what my favorite band is I don't
know who my favorite philosopher is you
know I I guess you could say my favorite
stoic quote is whenever I happen to you
know find helpful for me when I get into
a shitty situation they have to figure
out how to respond appropriately you
know then I'm happy to have that quote
ready at hand but I'm not a big like you
know I'm sort of like Seneca he's got
this great letter was letter 33 I think
and his buddy Luke Ilyas is saying hey
man give me some quotes right he's
asking for the you know some passages
and Seneca says how the hell am I going
to pick you know they're all good you
know there's there's so many good ones
in here and they don't they don't stand
out above each other because they're
they're all on the same level you know
stoicism is a complex system and then
after
of course Seneca says well I guess I'll
give you some so typical Seneca all
right a lot of back and forth about the
different political things
[Music]
Anastasia would you can personally
consider stoicism and active life
affirming philosophy I think Nietzsche's
main problem with it was considering it
primarily the philosophy of indifference
yeah I think Nietzsche got stoicism
wrong probably in part because most
people around him were getting stoicism
wrong that was a common thing in the
19th century actually in the 18th
century as well because human also gets
stoicism wrong and I think there were a
lot of people who were behaving in the
way that nature is criticizing the
Stoics as behaving it but what I
consider stoicism an act of life
affirming philosophy yeah definitely I
mean it certainly isn't in the classic
Stoics Epictetus is life-affirming
you know Senecas life-affirming people
well why'd he commit suicide then well
you know that's because Nero wouldn't he
hadn't committed suicide Nero would have
confiscated everything and his family
would have been you know if not killed
certainly in in terrible condition you
know so he only killed himself once
where is he behaved like a stoic pretty
much for you know time after time after
time so yeah James L dr. sailor to plays
devil play devil's advocate why should
we create justice and a fundamentally
unjust world seems like uniquely human
concept yeah that's exactly it why
shouldn't we create justice then why
shouldn't we Express what humanity is
well who says that if the world is
shitty that we have to leave it shitty I
mean do you do that at campsites you you
know you go and you're like well I mean
everybody's gonna screw it up anyway so
I'm just gonna like throw my crap around
everywhere and you know I'm not gonna
clean up after myself no you you try to
leave things in a better condition
that's that's part of what makes us
human
oh yeah I mean Stoics didn't think that
justice was a uniquely human concept but
they they also thought that rational
beings existed beyond the the realm of
the human all right so just jumped again
let's see what we've got here let's see
here Daniel s do you think there are any
undisciplined Stoics yeah cuz Stoics
don't claim to be gods or totally
impeccable or in you know you start in
any virtue ethics you're gonna screw up
a lot at the start and you're probably
gonna keep on screwing up too you know
and then you get some things worked out
and then you're like oh man this part of
my life I've more or less fixed but now
I see how screwed up this other part is
you know that's natural and that goes
for any virtue ethics so you know that's
I think that's kind of common James says
this theme of discipline is fascinating
for the Stoics it seems in a chose
extent of this to its conclusion is
discipline a necessary ingredient to
fruitful philosophy yeah I mean pretty
much pretty much anything that you're
going to try to develop you you have to
have some discipline with it even like
getting yourself to the gym takes
discipline and then you know actually
doing the stuff at the gym or you know
learning and instruments you know
everything takes discipline to some
degree I guess sometimes even enjoying
yourself the right way takes a little
bit of disciplining so alright too
Peter says thank you very much for your
discussion of justice and sometimes
stoically bothered by online Stoics
would criticize pro justice Stoics and
have an individualistic internal view of
stoicism yeah I'd say they're not
they're not understanding stoicism
adequately and they're reading very
selectively and they're probably doing
so so they can you know appeal to their
own emotional need for security you know
you ask yourself why did why do people
have this very individualistic
conception of stoicism is like it's
insulation against the world
it's uh you know actually Margaret
graver by the way you can find this in
stoicism today if you just go to modern
stoicism calm and you know the search
thing put engraver she gave a really
really good talk at a couple as couples
stoic cons ago the one in Toronto two
two years ago three years ago three
years ago where she was distinguishing
epicurean cynic and stoic approaches to
things to to emotions and she said the
cynics are trying to develop a hard
outer shell the Stoics are not the
Stoics are trying to become resilient
and genuine resiliency would be engaging
with your fellow human being the Stoics
think that were social beings as
rational beings so if we're
individualistic there's there's there's
something wrong with that stoicism it's
not authentically stoic alright
here's a good one from LA sure and
advice marcus aurelius gave when it
comes to confronting somebody's behavior
shouldn't it should be done privately
not publicly is it possible that this
idea came because of the fact that
Socrates got killed since so many just
liked him due to losing arguments
probably not it's probably more that you
know Marcus didn't have to worry about
anyone killing him other than you know
in war he was the Emperor so he's not
gonna he's not gonna have that going on
and people more or less liked him he was
one of the he was the last good Emperor
right and so you know I think with
Marcus it would be more listen why
should we put somebody on the spot and
embarrass them why not take them aside
and talk to them privately which is
often good advice you know in the
workplace or things like that all right
I'm gonna have to get going pretty soon
because my soon I'm gonna have to hit it
hit the shower and get dressed because
my wife is gonna be back and we're
supposed to do some sort of event in
town some sort of tasting thing I think
taste of Milwaukee or something like
that which by the way I'll say this so
my wife were rightly recognized that
these things are frustrating for me we
go around and there's all these little
tiny bits of food right and and you
they're all basically a mousse bouche
right in in culinary terms and you see
it take a little bit of that and then
like you know sip a little bit of beer
basically everything's in thimbles you
know manure get enough when you do these
sorts of things I think little twig like
people who are five feet tall probably
yes but a six foot three guy no you know
and you don't want to ask for like extra
portions because then you look like a
pig or something all right all right
back to this this I don't know how many
questions on long story short I don't
know how many other questions all
actually
have so let's see here old rustic house
how do I apply stoicism to life after
work where I read and think and solve
problems all day I get so tired and feel
the urge to veg out but no there is more
fruitful activities okay well you
probably do need to to veg out if you're
working and and you know exercising your
mind all day
what about you know you know programming
into your day like half an hour you
don't have to like be be like
Machiavelli right
who would do his day job as an
administrator of Florence and then go to
his home and take off his work clothes
and put on his robes and go into his
study and commune with Livie and the
ancients all night you know a lot of us
have to do you know jobs that are quite
draining if you can make you know 15
minutes or 20 minutes or half an hour
for yourself to do a little bit of
reading and so maybe some guided
meditation or something like that it'll
it'll help you and then you know you can
also you can also it you know like on
your way to work or something like that
maybe listen to a podcast or you know
you could even break up your day with
with some stuff you don't have to try to
do everything all at once so alright to
do mathias says aren't the Platonic
philosophers the true inheritance of a
lot phyllis ophea what is the doctrine
of Stoics on the one what zeus right so
it's the logos that runs through
everything
by the way plenty of neoplatonist picked
up stuff from the Stoics just like they
did with the Aristotelian as I thought
well we need Plato for like the high up
stuff and then got to have something
else for the
intra mundane level I've been actually
working through some clicky is's
commentary on
Epictetus is enchiridion very
interesting stuff to see how they blend
these things together so alright let's
see if there's any others I can go out
on ok so here's something a good one
something you said you can practice
stoicism all you want you still have a
breaking point you still have a
threshold of Tolerance just don't
overestimate stoicism is potential like
anything else it has its limits yeah and
actually I would say you have your
limits I mean if you think that some
sort of ism is gonna like fix your life
altogether yeah you're setting yourself
up for problems genuine stoicism would
be something that would be reflexive it
would take stock of itself every once in
a while
I mean you notice that Epictetus doesn't
just in his teachings doesn't just say
and it's already been talked about in
cruciferous I don't have to think about
this at all you know just read the book
right and he adds to it he's continually
reinterpreting stoicism and that's how
it adapts itself and that's that's why I
think modern stoicism is you know in
some respects the the more superior
strain than traditional stoicism but
yeah you're right
everybody does have a breaking point
now the stoicism would say your breaking
point can be a lot further along than
you think it is and you can certainly do
things to make yourself less affected by
stuff but yeah all right so that's
that's probably a good one to go out on
I'm already like 12 minutes 13 minutes
over what I was originally planning
thanks for all of your questions and
comments glad you could be here I'm
gonna do another pop up later on this
month
probably will not be about stoicism or
virtue ethics as such I'm thinking that
the next pop up I might you know I might
do like one like this each month on
either on stoicism aristotelianism or
something along those lines something in
virtue ethics but I'm thinking I kind of
feel like you know I I should do
something that I would like to do that I
don't get to do because I do like to do
this but I don't get to do all that
often which is to talk about classic
metal so I think I might make the next
pop up later on this month be about that
but we'll see how how that works out so
have a for me it's it's night have a
good whatever it is for you evening
morning afternoon night so and I'll see
you probably next big online event we
have is the AMA so I'll see you then